who is most likely to show up late to
practice I was gonna say Fargo man I'm
gonna say Melvin most likely to spend
five hours on Tick Tock Brandon Jones
man that boy stay on Tick Tock every day
I get on there you got two new videos
three new videos up most likely to be
king of the aux cord on a road trip that
might be me yeah cause I feel like I
ain't we ain't had nobody really take
charge of the ox and locker room playing
hits but it ain't nobody like really
taking charge of it most likely to eat
the cleanest probably Jalen Phillips
dude look like an action figure most
likely to eat the most at a team dinner
John Jenkins I'm just saying that
because I'm a dog big
he'll come ask you about that tomorrow
I know he's a big dude so I'm gonna just
give it to him who's most likely to pick
up the tab uh now it's me bro man I'm
trying to slide the card in without
everybody seeing and stuff like that
most likely to start in the movie tour
Tariq they're the Stars man they do
everything they need to be done on the
field the acting skills probably a one
so I give it one of them boys for sure
most likely to uh finish a thousand
piece puzzle I say on the wheels I don't
even know if he could but his locker
right next to mine so I'm gonna say him
most likely to have the best cologne
probably my dog Fargo again male again
you know I'm saying he's going to stay
with with all the all the latest you
know what I mean so you're probably
gonna smell the best too